-Welcome.
-Thank you.
It's been a while.
It's great to be back with you.
-And I'm so always flattered
and honored that you come up
right after you finish your job,
because you just
finished taping "Nightly."
-I stay after school for you.
-Thank you so much.
You know, we always
have this problem
where stuff happens
late in the day.
This seemed to be one
of those days
where you probably had to cover
some of the Manafort trial
and some of stuff that happened
in the later part of the day.
-Yeah, it feels like --
you know,
we used to talk about
a 24-hour news cycle.
Now it's down to
about two hours.
-Yeah.
-And it's, you know,
we always get the broadcast set
and we're feeling good about
where it is, and then
usually about 5:00,
something falls out of the sky
and then we're, you know,
we're on to the next thing.
-I assume you
and your team have gotten
a little bit better
at handling it
as this two-hour cycle continues
to get shorter and shorter?
-You know, as I say,
that's how we roll.
That's what we do.
-That's wonderful to hear.
This is the thing
that keeps coming up
that I always want to
ask you about.
You asked Donald Trump
a question,
a pretty normal question
in an interview
about the firing of James Comey.
It is now the most replayed clip
because this is where
he basically admitted
that he did fire Comey because
of the Russia investigation.
Did you know
when that was happening,
when he was giving that answer,
that it was newsworthy?
-I knew the interview
was newsworthy.
I know he was opening up about
something that, you know --
and it just happened
a few days earlier.
From the time we booked
the interview and arranged it
to the time we actually
sat down,
the middle of that is when
the Comey firing occurred.
So we knew the thrust
of the conversation
would be about that.
I wasn't surprised
by his forthrightness.
That's who he is.
He tends to own things.
I'd interviewed him,
you know, going back
to the "Apprentice" days,
so I wasn't shocked.
You know, he continued to talk.
And I continued to try
and make sure I was clarifying
because sometimes in interviews,
you know,
things happen very quickly
and someone will listen
to one little thing.
"What did he mean?"
I wanted to make sure
that I understood exactly,
you know,
what his position was.
But I will say every journalist
wants their work
to have some impact.
It is a little surreal.
I'll sit in my office
sometimes and look up
and see clips of that again.
-It's also interesting,
one of the reasons
I think it endures as well,
not just from the information,
it was not a "gotcha" question.
And it was a very politely
conducted interview,
even when you interrupt
to ask for clarification.
It seems like you're
trying to help him
make the point he makes,
which is then the point
that is being used against him
so often.
-Yeah, and I appreciate that.
[ Laughter ]
I appreciate that.
I mean, I tell people,
any journalist would have
asked virtually the same
questions given the timing
of when that interview happened.
They were -- you know,
it was pretty obvious
that we needed to understand
why this firing had occurred.
And he was, you know, as I
suspected he would, he owned,
you know,
his position on that.
And, you know, they were --
ended up getting a little
more time than I thought.
You know, sometimes in these
kind of interviews
when you've got a big,
important person,
you're playing the clock.
"Okay, I want to get this
question, but I better jump
to the next one because
I may run out of time."
-Sure.
-This mental gymnastics
is going on the whole time.
But in the end, you know,
we got a good amount of time
and got to explore a lot.
-Do you think based on that,
he has hesitation
of sitting down with you again,
because it went so badly
for him in retrospect?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I mean, I don't know.
I mean, you know, I don't know
whether he thinks it went badly
or, you know --
it's not for me to judge.
-He thinks it went badly
for you.
He did tell me that.
[ Laughter ]
-Well...
I would obviously welcome
another chance
to sit down with him.
That opportunity has not --
you know, has not
knocked on my door.
-Well, you are --
I hate to break this to you --
you are a member of the media,
and you, as a collective,
as has been explained to me
by our President,
are an enemy of the people.
And he's recently tweeted that
you are dangerous and sick.
Is it strange to be representing
a profession right now
that the President
of the United States
is just full bore attacking
on a daily basis?
-You know, I let the --
I let the "fake news" stuff
roll off my back.
It's not fun.
But I think most people
understand
an organization like ours,
and a lot of the organizations
under fire,
have been doing this
for decades and decades.
And we've earned a lot of trust
with our audiences
and a tradition of excellence.
So I let -- I let that roll.
I think where I draw the line,
though, is the safety
and well-being of my colleagues.
And "enemy of the people"
I think crosses a line.
I think it's reckless.
I respectfully ask that it end.
And that's what I have to say
about it.
-I also respectfully...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...ask that it end.
And...
I will say, I have some bad news
for both of us
based on how respectfully
asking is working.
[ Laughter ]